we are designed by evolution to be
titillated by erotic novelty males and
females given that evolutionary design
it's completely predictable that ten
years of the same thing whether it's the
same music or the same food or the same
sex partner is going to lead to
resentment discomfort whatever it's
going to lead to a diminishment of
passion certainly so we start with that
and then we add to that the the notion
that were taught that that shouldn't
happen that if it does happen there's
something wrong with you or something
wrong with your relationship and so
people aren't expecting that to happen
and so they interpret that diminishment
of passion as a failure the point that
we're trying to get across in the book
is that it's not your fault it's not
your partner's fault it's the fault of
the clash between the sort of animal we
are and the sort of society we've
designed and as long as there's that
conflict between our biology and our
societies there are going to be these
problems so a harm reduction approach
might make a lot more sense than the
sort of absolutist approach that a lot
of people take where any infidelity any
you know my husband looks at porn that
means he doesn't love me anymore I mean
these sorts of responses to very natural
behaviors cause a lot more problems than
they solve I think I think if marriage
is going to survive as an institution
it's going to certainly have to continue
adapting to the realities of human
nature as opposed to trying to shoehorn
human nature into some predetermined
shape the point of marriage is that you
want to get old with someone you want to
share your life with someone maybe you
want to raise children with someone you
want to have a certain stability and
trust that you couldn't possibly get
with short-term relation
chips that's the point of marriage and
by imposing this expectation of sexual
exclusivity for 40 50 60 years we're
cutting ourselves off from those really
important things for something that's
essentially trivial sex isn't really
that important it's not that big a deal
and by making it such a big deal we
sabotage things that really are
important these primary relationships we
have children you know going through
divorces that victimized by the the
psychological trauma of divorce over
what over what that mommy or daddy had
sex with someone else who cares the
problem is much like the war on drugs
the problem is that we take this
absolutist approach to something that
people are always going to do people are
always going to smoke marijuana people
are always gonna drink alcohol and
coffee and whatever but we make these
arbitrary judgments on what's acceptable
in what isn't that have nothing to do
with the actual harm that any of these
things could cause to people so we throw
people in prison for for you know
growing a marijuana plant on their
windows so it makes no sense it causes
much more harm than than just letting
people do what they want to do and
really whose business is it if a couple
decides that they're going to you know
allow a little casual sexual behavior on
the side especially if as dan savage
argues and and I agree it takes the
pressure off the relationship if the
door is open a little bit you don't feel
trapped it doesn't mean the door has to
be swung wide open but it you know the
fact that it's open a little bit doesn't
mean that the marriage is a farce
certainly
you